what's going on guys
don't I look fancy that's because I am
celebrating made man's gentleman up
formal Friday initiative and what better
way to celebrate formal Friday than to
talk about the best dressed director in
all of Hollywood Christopher Nolan he's
also dropping interstellar upon us so
that's pretty exciting too today we are
going to break down Christopher Nolan
films and we're gonna come to a
conclusion what is the greatest
Christopher Nolan film of all time we've
got a super cool panel dude with first
he is the founder of eimacher EECOM and
one of the creators of abobo's big
adventure roger bar thanks for having me
back hell and I wore my formal attire as
well you know where you'll love her
she's an actress she's a hostess she
does a little bit of everything
Alison Haislip hello he's a best-selling
author and the man behind the best show
in the universe Maddox yeah how does my
second vest a Honda shirt so guys here's
what we're gonna do we took the top
eight Christopher Nolan films according
to their IMDB ranks put them together in
a march madness style bracket and we're
going to decide which one reigns supreme
let's kick this off at the first battle
you have the number 8 film versus the
number one film insomnia versus the dark
night let's go down on the end and start
with Maddox yeah the dark night hands
down I take issue with anyone who has a
problem with this movie if you have
problems maybe I prom with you I have a
friend of mine who has made his own edit
of this movie where he cut the entire
almost the entire two-face part of the
movie because he didn't like to face as
a character like you're an idiot
it's a perfect movie don't touch it but
he also has narcolepsy like he's been
diagnosed with narcolepsy so I'm like is
this a real person so what he doesn't
have is insomnia oh I'm actually one of
the few people who saw insomnia in the
theaters okay huge fan may he rest in
peace of Robin Williams in that mode I'm
you like we just got to see this like
other side of him that we don't get to
see in any other film that being said
I'm still going dark night because it's
just it's so epic
yeah there's no arguing like this is
this is a roll over dark night over
insomnia moving on to the next round
alright let's talk about the number four
film against the number five
I film the prestige hmm the number for
film memento Alison you're the most put
off by this I am because these are
legitimately my two favorite Christopher
Nolan like I like these movies better
than Dark Knight oh wow okay these are
um like iron I remember so clearly
seeing memento back in like what 2001 oh
yeah I remember going to the theater and
having my mind blown oh yeah that film
was like an insect that you had up in my
ear and laid eggs in my dress then I
also remember seeing the prestige in
theaters oh god if I have to pick one
oh want to phone a friend I'm gonna go
no I'm gonna go a memento because even
though it's been over a decade since it
came out I solve such a clear feeling of
like that movie being like this is the
kind of movies that I want to do alright
let's let's go to Roger momento I agree
was it I mean that's the thing that
that's what everyone learned about
Christopher Nolan because of that movie
and it's an incredible movie it's
complicated
but everyone still loved it but I still
the prestige has stuck with me I've seen
that movie probably a hundred times now
oh absolutely
you're kidding no no I've never I
haven't seen love any movie a hundred
times yeah I really love that movie it
takes the cake for me so I got to go
with prestige on this one Maddox this
comes down to you my man well the
procedure what I liked about that film
is there was so much unnecessary death I
feel that was just written into into the
plot where essentially if I remember
correctly was a clone he was cloning
himself and killing himself over and
over again personally I would fight
myself and because at the end of every
generation the best version of me is
going on until at the end of it like
after I'd killed myself thousands and
thousands of times there's gonna be a
super me wait so that's your choice yes
with prestige I'm moving on
prestige knocking out memento that is an
upset the number five seed knocked out
the number four seed oh and I was making
it further let's move to the next
matchup Batman Begins at number six
against the number three Dark Knight
Rises let's start with Maddox
okay so Batman Begins I didn't like as
much as everyone else really and Dark
Knight Rises was a huge piece of is
there one that you would pick
Batman Begins because that's when
Commissioner Gordon really shined so 104
Batman Begins I'm against great um let's
go back around to Roger yeah I gotta go
with Batman Begins it's it's a better
story overall I do love the Dark Knight
Rises it's a fun movie to watch if you
can turn your brain off
but yeah Batman Begins I mean that
that's that everything you know that's -
Oh Batman again it's gonna move on our
final matchup of the first round oh wow
the number two film Inception against
his very first film ranked at number
seven following so let's go through this
one let's start with Roger
um inception verse following inception
inception Allisyn inception Maddox I'm
gonna go follow me okay screw you shut
up I'm more shocked about the fact that
following is ranked higher than insomnia
yeah we are yeah um you know what maybe
worth checking out okay guys we are in
the semi-finals aka the Final Four Dark
Knight versus the prestige let's start
with Alison Haislip I'm going prestige I
was so affected by that movie in the
theaters dark night obviously is
fantastic and brilliant but at no point
in that movie did I feel like I had my
mind blown by anything the procedure
twists me Oh
like I felt mildly violated after seeing
the prestige of cuz what that scene was
where were you on a bad date or
something no no um so yes I'm going
prestige prestige yeah okay one Oh
prestige Wow let's go to Maddox gotta go
with the Dark Knight on this based on
the strength of Heath Ledger's
performance I generally don't care about
acting and all that like Hollywood Bowl
but um this movie pulled me to the dark
side one-one Dark Knight prestige yeah
Heath Ledger's performance excellent
Roger bar uh you got to break the tie
this this is tough these comes down to
you these are my two favorite to handle
this job deciding as much as I've seen
the procedure I've also seen the Dark
Knight uh probably about as much over a
hundred times Lee I to Hydra get out of
here no getting to stay here all I do is
watch these two movies that is what I do
with my life
Wow I think I gotta go with
the dark night I mean there's there's a
reason it's ranked in you know like the
top ten on IMDB it's just it's just the
perfect superhero movie as far as I know
a lot of people love Avengers and
they're excited about that but I just
don't think it gets better than that
Dark Knight moving on Roger let me ask
you one question did you hear about this
guy who edited out all of the Harvey
Dent two-face stuff from that never mind
okay
let's go to our next Final Four matchup
Wow this is another barnburner Batman
Begins versus Inception we're gonna go
back around into the middle and start
with Alison Haislip all right
movies like Inception of the reason I
love Christopher Nolan I love movies
that make me think that make me solve
puzzles that make me try to figure out
what's going on while I'm puzzled I have
a friend who nicknamed me puzzles
watching that movie the entire movie was
me trying to figure out what was going
on and how they were gonna get out of
this and like what was happening you
know and like at the top at the end I'm
like what you know so so I'm gonna go
inception Roger bar how many times have
you seen inception not as much inception
I I do like a lot um
and Shep inception gave us ball
I hate Leonardo DiCaprio though I'm what
I am NOT a fan of Leo I about the wall
foot about what the wall street look he
peaked with What's Eating Gilbert Grape
as far as luck yeah you peaked when you
said you saw Dark Knight a hundred times
all right I disagree we disagree on Leo
I'm gonna put that out of fun let it
continue but that said I did enjoy
inception a lot yeah it was great movie
I loved all the layers just piling upon
each other on the whole story and I got
to go with inception because I think it
had the better ending of the two movies
I love that they just leave the little
spinning top spinning there and it cuts
out so left up to the audience to decide
boom there you go inception moving on
we're down to our final matchup Dark
Knight versus inception Roger bar let's
kick it off with you yeah I mean
inception barely squeaked out in the
last round for me and the Dark Knight is
a far better movie as far as I'm
concerned so I have to go with Dark
Knight 1 Oh Dark Knight / inception
Alison Haislip Oh for the reasons I just
said I'm going inception cuz I love I
love puzzles
I love figuring stuff out and inception
was far more exciting for my brain but
the Joker the Joker gave the entire city
puzzles to like that is whoo but you
watch them solve them it wasn't left up
to us you weren't piecing together the
plotline of the movie because of the
Joker's puzzles but you were pleased
piecing together the plotline of
Inception because of all these like
tricky things that they were doing so
yeah I'm going I'm going inception we
are all tied up at 1-1 it all comes down
to Maddox you know I agree with Allison
inception had such good puzzles in it
and the top at the end was the only time
I've stayed that attentive during a
movie during the NCN of a movie every
single person's eyes in that theater
were watering because nobody wanted to
blink and miss it that's it I like
puzzles and the puzzle with the Dark
Knight was how can a movie be this good
uh it's it it beats it out by a squeak
but Dark Knight there you have it Dark
Knight the greatest Christopher Nolan
film of all time what do you think the
best Christopher Nolan film of all time
is let us know in the comments section
below
best answer uh
but we're gonna send you a screen
junkies t-shirt please don't forget
about the work we're doing with made man
and gentleman up help us go formal on
Friday November 7th to support men in
need to learn more about this very cool
program check out the link in the
description below I want to thank my
awesome panel you guys rocked it hard
roger bar check out i mockery Alison
Haislip you do not have my permission to
die you have my permission to stay
wonderful and maddux best page in the
universe best-selling author check out
all his stuff check them all out on
Twitter follow me on Twitter I'm at Hal
Rudnick thank you for watching bye bye
hey screen junkies join made man and go
formal this Friday November 7th click
the link in the description below to
participate bye bye